I started out as a veterinarian and was
blessed and working with some of the
biggest Sue's and some big animal
populations and one of my favorite
stories was the bears around the world
they were dying of liver cancer all over
the world it didn't matter if they were
a polar bear a black bear or Sun bear a
Kodiak bear it didn't matter what
species they were and it didn't matter
what zoo or what country they came from
they're all dying of liver cancer and
Marlin Perkins my old mutual Mahalo
Kingdom show I had worked with him and
he say okay Wallach is going to start
this big project of for the National
Institutes of Health doing autopsies was
1967 and just came back from Africa and
Perkins gave me this list he says here's
a list of things that I personally want
you to do while you're doing this
project for the NIH and I looked at and
the first thing on the list was why are
all the Bears regardless of species all
over the world dying from liver cancer
and he says the biologists had surgeon
etic thing what do you think and he said
well certainly not a genetic thing if
every species all over the world of
bears are dying of liver cancer I said
but I think I know what it is he says
well you haven't even seen anything
slides nothing well there is a
particular fungus that actually causes
liver cancer called aflatoxin very
common and peanuts and most bears sell
peanuts at the zoo's so people can throw
them to the Bears you know so they could
stand up and they take pictures of them
waving at the crowd to get attention so
they can get the peanut so let's culture
some of these peanuts who are on these
zoos around the world and we can also if
you take a ultraviolet light and go in
the dark and go to these peanuts in the
barrel or the drum or the basket and put
that ultraviolet light on it if there is
this aflatoxin in there that causes the
liver cancer it'll glow in the night
it'll glow okay like a Firefly and sure
enough and all the zoos around the world
the peanuts are feeding the Bears had
aflatoxin they're all going and we're
able to make sure that all this is when
they would get peanuts to feed the
animals
with that ultraviolet I don't make sure
that none with the aflatoxin came in
there and we stopped the liver cancer
epidemic and the Bears around the world
one of the other things that would go on
with that was the old bread of course it
was a thing they could buy cheaply and
you know one loaf of bread be 1500
calories and it was um moldy bread you
know from the various bread companies
would sell them to the zoos and so forth
and of course we put that ultraviolet
light on him the bread was light up but
because the mold on the bread was
cousins to the mold on the peanuts and
they would also produce aflatoxins so
they had to give up the bread as well as
the peanuts so it was quite the story
and it made the front pages and
magazines and the senton the other and
of course it's in the book epigenetics
it's in the book doctors and wives it's
in the book rarest men men cures because
it was a big story and of course the
same thing is true for people would be
very interesting to find out what the
percentage of liver cancer is on
homeless people that get old bread okay
given to them which has mold on they
throw away the two or three slices of
bread that had the mold on it but that
alpha toxin has seeped into all the
other I want to know what the rate of
liver cancer is on the homeless people
compared with middle-class people who
have a job and only buy fresh bread that
doesn't have mold on to be very
interesting well we actually switched
the Bears to dog food dry dog food we
just had to get dry dog food it didn't
have any gluten in it and so he switched
them to dry dog food and remember that
was in 1967 we ended the the bear liver
cancer epidemic and of course it's one
of those things were I'm very very proud
of that it is rare that one person's
experience added to telephones and
letters and we didn't have emails and
stuff like that back then if they did I
didn't know it and so it's all done by
letters and phone calls and just think
of that we were able to and the best
biologists in the world hadn't figured
it out and we're dealing with liver
cancer and polar bears Kodiak bears
black bears son bears brown bears every
kind of buried think of pandas because
they're all being treated the same diet
wise and so it was quite the the project
the results were stunning and I was very
very prominent so I was just a blessed
will give us a good Lord all the credit
and I was just so happy and proud that I
was the instrument to make the good
things happen one of the great rare and
endangered species of course is the
giant panda and one of the reasons why
it was rare and endangered in captivity
in the zoo's goes back to the beginning
of zoos you know hundreds of years ago
maybe even thousand years ago in the
days of the Roman Empire but people say
well pandas never produced babies in
zoos and it's because you know they're
so sensitive and people are looking at
them in the zoo and it's just well what
do you feed them well we're giving them
bamboo just like they live on in the
wild and so I kind of looked it up and I
came back and said well you know the
pandas eat more than bamboo they ate
bamboo the eight rats they catch birds
eat eggs the potatoes I mean they're
kind of like a bear they're omnivorous a
eat a lot of stuff a lot of little
vertebrates as they can catch including
mice and squirrels and rabbits and all
kinds of things and so their diet is a
lot more complicated than just giving
them bamboo so again we began to just
like the Bears who began to give them
dog food and we kind of mix it up dry
dog food and the canned dog food and
within a year's time all the zoos in
Europe and all the zoos in North America
are having babies so again like the bear
thing the liver cancer the pandas
breeding in captivity are based on just
simple stuff that again the average
person doesn't think about you know they
take from lack of experience and they go
read well being a pandas living in the
bamboo forest and and that's what they
eat okay and so they went out of their
way and they did everything they could
to get fresh bamboo sprouts for the
pandas but then it wasn't
didn't have enough nutrition to support
conception and pregnancy so again we
saved a class of animals based on just
proper nutrition
well now the pandas are almost a burden
in this is because they all have babies
and so they do have panda reserves in
China which we do cooperate and the
pandas get shipped to places where they
don't have them in zoos and also where
they have the panda reserves in China so
the pandas are not endangered anymore
because we've found how to make sure
that they all have babies at the Chicago
Aquarium the porpoises and dolphins were
all having problems and dying of heart
failure and those having the other and
he comes down to there's a certain kind
of fish it has thiamine ace in it
diamond ace is a is an enzyme that
destroys vitamin b1 thiamine and
thiamine deficiency causes congestive
heart failure and so you know we're
talking about sardines and things like
that and these small fish
which were easy for zoos to get and keep
in the freezer and the porpoises and
dolphins loved him and everybody was
happy and so we began to switch to
different types of fish that did not
have those diamond ace enzymes we gave
him the 90 essential nutrients which all
vertebrates need including porpoises and
dolphins and we gave him extra of the
Thiemann just in case some etomidate's
got in there and we ended all the
congestive heart failure deaths in the
porpoises in captivity but why is this
happening well it turns out for years
and years and years and years that
aquariums had trouble keeping dolphins
alive for long periods of time
particularly the ones that used those
fish that had the thiamine ACE enzyme
and the tissues and nobody made that
connection well you have to appreciate
by the time that I got there I'd already
done 20,000 autopsies and 17,000 and
change or foreign 54 species of animals
including dolphins and porpoises and
whales and and so forth
I was very familiar with whales of all
sizes and species and so
it comes down to my training as
pathologist and so when you have
populations showing the same problem
it's gonna be very easy to solve the
problem now to geneticists it well it's
a genetic thing it's send out all the
dolphins well no there's other options
here where they're being fed but what do
they drink for water or there what is
the water and the tank being cleaned
with and so forth just filters or
chemicals or what and so they have to
look at the environment you have to look
at their food and I have solved so many
problems for domestic animals also for
so many animals in captivity and this
includes birth defects and and so forth
so we're very very proud of that and
basically the problem was they were just
being fed fish because again they would
ask a veterinarian they would ask a
doctor and they say oh you know just
feed him well they'll get everything
they need and trying to keep expenses
down instead of of giving them the 92
cents of nutrients they would just give
them the whole fish well we're giving
the whole fish that's with eat out in
the wild well where those fish come from
that him of the thigh may dominate
enzyme in the tissue
there's no dolphins and whales there in
those places okay and the people who eat
those fish by catching them you know
either a spear a filter a net or
something they're eating all kinds of
other things so eating sure the three of
those little fish twice a week is not a
problem but if they only ate those fish
three times a day is their only meal and
they'd have a problem congestive heart
failure just like the dolphins when it
comes to other animals and people always
ask me well okay what about big
vertebrates you know like cattle and
horses and and so forth if they were
having congestive heart failure
that would mean they're either in
getting some diamond ace enzyme
somewhere or they're getting fed food
that didn't make those vitamins okay
Diamond and so thiamine is actually made
by grain okay well grain has its hazards
because of the gluten in it and so it's
one of those things were where they see
will eat whole grains you get vitamins
well yeah you do especially in the brand
but that's where most of the gluten is
and so that's not my first choice as a
sore
of thiamine okay
especially in domestic livestock were
they have no health insurance for the
animals we can send them to a
cardiologist to get congestive heart
failure no you give them all 92 cents of
nutrients you give them a trace mineral
salt block and the need for medical care
or veterinary care of livestock such as
again as cattle and horses and sheep and
and pigs and goats and poultry chickens
and turkeys and things is almost zero
because you're getting all these
nutrients in in their supplement
programs and farmers do this without the
need to go to a veterinarian this is
either what they learn in agricultural
school or the feed salesman to go
through those communities they'll stop
at every farm they'll say hey you know
you can you know reduce a lot of these
health problems your calves will be
better off and not have all these
problems by giving the mothers these
vitamins and minerals and they come
through the milk and you know the camp
start eating whole foods they need their
own supply and so forth and this is one
of the reasons why I knew we could
really take veterinary nutritional
supplement programs and devise a similar
program for humans because all
vertebrates require the same nutrients
and always get the same diseases from
the same deficiencies so why wouldn't
the process processes we did with
animals work on humans and sure enough
it worked more the areas one of the
great areas that I learned from the
animal industry and carried it over into
human life is that birth defects were
fairly rare in livestock cattle and
sheep and horses and pigs and stuff like
that they occurred but they occurred
randomly maybe two farms in a County in
Missouri might have this problem because
those defects are caused by a mineral
deficiency and they didn't have those
minerals in the soil there and they
weren't supplamine in any particular way
with that mineral and that's why they
had the birth defects and the brothers
and sisters of those same animals and
five farms over didn't have any problems
and so the first one I ran into was
really spectacular I had graduated
veterinary school I was kind of halfway
through my degree in pathology from the
nerdist Missouri I went to Iowa State to
finish it off
Marlin Perkins before I got finished he
sent me to Africa to work on the white
rhino conservation project and two years
into that he had me come back because he
got this grant based on one of my
research projects 25 million dollars to
do those autopsies one of the places I
was working was at the Yerkes primate
Center in Atlanta Georgia these were the
big NASA monkey colonies were and I was
a veterinarian and a pathologist there
and I was also working on human
pathology at Grady Memorial Hospital in
Atlanta and I ran into the first
non-human case of cystic fibrosis
supposed to be the classic example of a
genetically transmitted disease in
humans psittacosis and I did my little
review here and it turns out I was able
to get permission to do biopsies of the
other 24 baby monkeys in the colony all
of whom had different mothers and
fathers there was 25 pairs of monkeys
every one of them had babies at the same
time they kind of controlled the
breeding day so they're all gonna be
they're gonna be born about the same
time and the first one that died I got
in the classic crib Rose says I
sent tissue around and to experts and he
said oh this is a classic example of
fibrosis and he said well this
happens to be from a monkey what you
found the first non-human case of cystic
fibrosis so everybody's excited and I
was in every newspaper I was in every
newspaper every day for three months
what a wonderful thing this was and
finally the scientists say okay Walt
like how long do you think it'll take
with breeding of that one monkey and
taking genes and doing artificial
insemination and all this kind of stuff
because we'll be able to get a hundred
baby monkeys to really do some research
on City Boro so say so I can do better
than that I can give you a thousand baby
monkeys in six months because it's not a
genetic disease actually a nutritional
deficiency of a single nutrient and I
can reproduce as many monkeys as you
want and they immediately fired me not
because they believed it was a genetic
disease and I was sniffing glue and I
was way off and the deep end and this
and the other but I had got permission
to biopsies of these other 24 baby
monkeys well guess what they all had
cystic fibrosis even though they had
brother there are mothers and fathers
they were not genetically related to
each other other than there were monkeys
but they weren't cousins or anything
like that because the monkeys were from
all over all over the India not just one
little County or anything and so I knew
that it wasn't genetic and so I started
really studying City boroughs as hard in
people and sure enough it's very very
simple disease easy to prevent that's a
deficiency really of two nutrients one
deficiency causes the pancreas and the
liver disease the other nutrition
deficiency causes the respiratory
problems which are classic usually the
terminal event of kids with City grosses
so to make a long story short I was able
to come up with a program for that and
went around the world and just call you
know gave lectures and so forth and came
up with programs and so today these kids
can live to be in their 70s and 80s and
90s back then there is the average
lifespan of these kids with cystic
fibrosis was five to seven they never
lived past twelve and some of these
places were the Amish of course the
colonies they had a high rate of city of
roses they also had a high rate of
mustard history
well most risky is very common in
animals it's a kind of called white
muscle disease now because when you
butcher them instead of having red
muscle like you know like a steak raw
steak is red okay this would be white or
yellow okay and they call it white
muscle disease well it's just mustard
history and animals they call it white
muscle disease and animals and moster
dystrophy in humans so we began to give
the kids in in the Amish communities
that had most recipe and city of roses
all 90 essential nutrients with more of
that mineral and we are actually
reversing city of roses and mustard
history within weeks and months is like
crazy okay and so I took several of
these files from kids we had reversed
their mustard history with and gave them
to Jerry Lewis two years before he died
and say Jerry this is for you we have
found the cause prevention and the
ability to reverse most resistant okay
using some
studies giving these kids these
nutrients and it turns out that muster
dystrophy is a nutritional deficiency
they can be born with it because Mom is
efficient I think we barn normal but
because they have a gluten intolerance
and can't absorb it if they're
supplementing they they can get most
history but it's a totally reversible
and preventable disease he got so
excited he took those records to the
most ERISA fee Association remember he
was doing telethon for 20 years raising
money for research and the genetics and
all that kind of stuff and mustard
history and they fired Jerry Lewis and
shut down the telethon that's why I
haven't heard anything about mustard
City fibrosis in the last 10 12 15 years
there aren't any cases anymore every
baby farmer by law now has to have this
nutrient now we're also able to end send
him a death syndrome crib death okay the
the failed theory was the crib death was
caused by mothers laying on the babies
in the crib well it turns out that only
2% of the babies who die of crib death
are in bed with her mothers when they
die
well they suffocate from the sheets and
blankets well I redid a lot of those
babies deaths as far as the autopsies
and none of them suffocated
they all died from hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease which is a
deficiency of a single nutrient the same
nutrient deficiency that kills young
athletes 25,000 a year in America under
the age of 20 I've done 1,700 autopsies
on kids that have died of that the
English is in three languages the
English version that is in the Journal
of trace element research it's also in
Mandarin and Cantonese but any rate
through federal court rulings that went
in our behalf as we've been after him
for years and years and years we were
putting what we call kids town he was a
liquid multiple we had people put in
their formulas but they knew they didn't
have that nutrient in there and sure
enough the rate of crib death was slowly
going down but we got this ruling April
16th 2013 a federal court which required
all manufacturers of baby formula to put
that nutrient in baby for almas within
three months a cover story front page
front page the Charlotte Observer which
is the big page in Charlotte North
Carolina big newspaper in Charlotte
carton North Carolina just like New York
Times in New York he said we don't know
why but
crib death has vanished in the state of
North Carolina trim months later
Missouri said the same thing three
months later all states said we don't
know why but the rate of crib death has
dropped dramatically by 85 to 95 percent
in her states
that's because baby farmers now had that
nutrient in there the reason why I was
dropping slowly over the years before
the court ruled to put that in baby farm
was we had her kids toddy and people
would come to our lectures of being
interviewed on TV and radio and so forth
and people knew to get that kids toddy
and putting their baby problem is to
prevent selling them in death syndrome
crib death and all so much history and
city grosses we're very very proud of
all that we had to sue the courts and
everything because we're getting rulings
ordering us to stop saying that we could
prevent reverse certain childhood
diseases and handle diseases using
vitamins and minerals because doctors
and hospitals and insurance companies
and people who were geneticists would go
to the courts and say this guy's a
veterinarian you wouldn't even a doctor
yet what are we talking about here he's
a veterinarian and he's saying all these
diseases we know of as a fact and I mean
you know we got all these ten professors
from the University who say it's a
genetic disease and he's saying is just
a simple nutritional deficiency and and
you know we don't want him to defraud
all these people and so I was able to
prove to the courts that I was correct
by having the records from the animals
showing that the same disease under the
microscope because their experts
couldn't tell whether it was from an
animal or a human well what would you
say this is oh that's miss is much
history which one is an animal which one
is a human okay well they couldn't
because muscle is muscle under the
microscope so those are the sort of
things that were able to do over the
years and and mostly it was legal stuff
okay because we knew we had the
prevention we knew we had the reversal
we knew it was diet and lack of
nutrients and we knew from the animal
studies in soil studies I also have a
degree in agriculture nutritional
minerals are not occurring a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth
they occur in veins like chocolate
chocolate ice cream okay that's why some
place in the world people live to be 200
some place in the world people
be 40 they could be first cousins and
that's because the the nutrients are not
found equally it's like gold mines are
not found equally around the world
that's when coal mines are not found
equally around the world
okay Silver's not found equally around
the world same thing with nutritional
minerals you know some simple ones like
iron and zinc and stuff like that but
also some very exotic ones are not found
equally around the world the places
where people live the longest and are
third world cultures they don't have
hospitals I think this is the thing that
that got the judges the most the people
who live the longest in the world were
from third world cultures the honza's
around the gilt our glacier in between
Pakistan and China they're the longest
of people in the world they're in the
top nineteen out of the top 20 longevity
cultures on earth they're third world
they have no doctors no medical doctors
from a medical school they have no
pharmaceuticals they have no hospitals
and they had absolutely they didn't have
any surgery and no absolutely they
didn't have any health insurance and yet
they had 40 times 100 olds we Americans
who he had 100 for 250 their population
according to the United Nations not me
and we only have one per 10,000 with all
the medicine we have and of course right
now the Center for Disease Control in
2004 came out and said oh our kids will
be the first generation of Americans
that do not live with other parents
that's that's a horrible failure of the
medical system for our kids are gonna be
the first generation of Americans that
do not live as long as their parents
it's a horrible horrible failure of the
medical system we have a lot of very
very talented lawyers and athletes and
pastors and even now we're getting
people who are in the academic field who
know we're quite correct I've written so
many scientific papers or in medical
journals and scientific journals we were
given awards by the United Nations and
all kinds of stuff so it's which I say
they may not like the fact that there is
being shown that a lot of their beliefs
and theories are incorrect okay they
don't like being told that they continue
to profess their false theories because
you know I can only soos Ali could
afford to sue so many people my priority
was the birth defects in kids and so I
was so happy to get that nutrient put
into baby for almost we were able to
essentially eliminate send them to death
syndrome mustards free and city grossest
we did get qualified health claims over
omega threes because we were able to
show that omega-3 deficiencies actually
caused coronary thrombosis blood clots
in coronary arteries from buttock stroke
of luck on the brain pulmonary embolism
blood clot in the lung deep vein
thrombosis of legs these are all caused
by omega-3 deficiencies and also those
deficiencies can also result in asthma
and that kind of stuff and so it's hard
to out theorize 32,000 autopsies okay
and all my projects I've done about
32,000 autopsy all published and so it's
unbeatable information and so when you
do 1700 autopsies on kids under the age
of 10 that have died of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease and you
come up with the nutrients that's
missing 35% of those 1,700 had
Gerber osis 100 sent head busters fee
and 200 of them under the age of 1 years
old had sent him a death syndrome and so
it's one of those things where it's
unimpeachable evidence it's published
and respected journals and so they
doctors still pursue their theories
because that's how they make their
living and that's why our children will
be the first generation Americans that
do not live with other parents our
animals are living longer and longer
longer and healthier the cost of farmers
and healthcare for livestock before this
shift in the market is almost zero
because they give them the nutrients in
1958 I started out my academic career in
agriculture at whim so that you know
Department of Agriculture University of
Missouri and two years into that I
applied for and got into veterinary
school
I kind of worked my way through
veterinary school working in the
pathology department as a student
assistant and they you know gave me a
couple hundred bucks a month plus I got
some credits towards a degree if I ever
wanted to do that I got credit for a
university degree in pathology and in
December of 1961 I was two years into my
pathology training six months for I got
my degree in agriculture and a couple
years before I got my degree in
bettering medicine and wrestling and at
the University of Missouri okay on their
team so I was a busy boy and everybody
is out for Christmas vacation okay cause
it's December I was the new guy on the
Block in the pathology department so all
the advanced students and the professors
were gone and I ran into the first mass
die-off intermarket America from
pollution I'm sure it had happened
before but nobody paid attention to it
they brought me fifty lambs these are
feeder lambs they were six months old
they're just two weeks from going to
market they were part of a flock of 500
lambs all 500 died in one night so they
brought me fifty opened up the first one
and as the blood came down over the wool
because I had two inches of wool they
were gonna shear him and then send him
off to market and of course they all
died in that one night well the blood
came out of that lamb and it looked like
chocolate milk instead of blood which is
called met hemoglobin it's caused by
nitrate poisoning and so he's okay he's
gotten some nitrates in the drinking
water or the hay or something so I just
marked that down and then I got up into
the neck of that first one and the
thyroid lobes and a six-month-old lamb
would be the size of a almond maybe half
inch long quarter inch wide maybe a
couple of millimeters sick
well these saturated lobes these two
lobes in his lamb were like big plums a
hundred times bigger than they were
supposed to be so I knew the nitrates
had been there long chronic time because
you get lighter from chronic low-grade
nitrate poisoning the question was why
did they 500 die in one night because if
you have a flock of lambs there's six
months old and they got whiter you might
have one died and if you let them live
maybe in a month or two another
we'll die or something like that all our
mark you're not going to die one night
that's that typical of a thyroid issue
and so I checked with a farmer and his
granddaughter was doing a high-low
temperature readings for her 4-h project
for three months before they all died
and then a couple weeks afterwards and
it turns out that the the temperature in
Central Missouri in the wintertime can
be very high could be in the 80s if the
wind is coming up from the Gulf of the
Mississippi River is coming down the
Mississippi River from Minnesota or
Wisconsin or Michigan that can be 19
degrees below zero turns out on the
night they all died the temperature
dropped to 19 they all died of
hypothermia Makeba Kaiser thyroids were
working being able to maintain their
body temperature and so I got it all
ready for publication and when the
professors and everybody came back from
the prison vacation it's 1961 21 years
old and ice okay here I got this this
and this this is it's all ready for
publication may I be a co-author on that
he says well we didn't do anything it's
all yours I said why I'm talking about
protocol look around the stem a student
no no you did the whole thing he figured
out this is yours I said wow thank you
sir so that was my first solo
publication I was a sole author on it
and I submitted it to veterinary
journals and got it published and gave
Kyle I was so excited I gave copies to
everybody they gave one copy to Marlin
Perkins my old mutual Mahalo Kingdom
show who I'd worked with as a kid before
I went to the University on my ultra
high school and summer times during the
University and he got a twenty five
million dollar grant from the National
Institute of Health from NIH he got a
twenty five million dollar grant to
study pollution and deaths and zoo
animals and pollution deaths and humans
living around the big so it's kind of
looking for the canary in the mine sort
of thing where there's bound to be a
species of animals in the zoo that was
sensitive the same pollutants as humans
and if they were to die we knew to
evacuate the cities that was a whole
purpose of that project and so that was
my my first autopsies by myself and it
was my first big project
we got it published and it resulted in a
twenty five million dollar grant from
NIH so I'm very very proud of that and
thankful to Merlin Perkins he recognized
the value of that thing I didn't
recognize the entire value of it but he
did he's oh my gosh and he used that to
apply for the twenty five million dollar
grant to do that autopsy study in the
big zoos around the United States and
North America and Canada and Mexico and
that's led to me working all over the
world at one twenty five million dollar
project added 20,000 autopsies 17,000
some change of over four hundred fifty
four species zoo animals and three
thousand people who lived around the zoo
everyone found out was there was no
deaths in the zoo's there was no deaths
and people living around the zoos from
pollution that was all kind of a fake
theory okay there was no deaths from
pollution and I also found out there was
no genetically transmitted diseases and
that began his long career before the
NIH NIH study I think probably I would
say I had done probably a thousand
autopsies you know couple of dozen
humans the rest were various beasts
mostly domestic animals a few exoti you
know llamas and farm animals like that
geese and sometimes they bring me 25
turkeys and have do autopsies and 25
turkeys because they had some dying and
stuff and to figure out why they were
dying of course I took him home and ate
him I was a poor student in the
pathology department there's a team you
give them the tissues a little bottle of
formaldehyde and they take the tissue
and make slides out of them and also you
take you know anything you want a
culture for bacteria viruses are fungus
you'd take swabs out of it and it's
Turrell swabs and put them in a test
tube and give them to the lab and they
will grow it and tell you what they grow
but I knew how to do all that kind of
stuff but you can't do all of it there's
just it's too much so you have a team
you have people who work in the lab some
that make the slides you know for
looking on the microscope some that work
with blood tests something work with
hair analysis some work
with microbiology and you're growing
bugs some deal with parasitology which
some you can see cutting a hole which
parasites era either in blood slides or
like malaria and things like that
trypanosomes in the butt in the blood
but when it comes to worms and the
intestines you usually see them because
you know you get a round worm eight ten
twelve inches long in a llama or a human
eye kind of thing and so some of those
things you could report and record and
just to know what species there are we
put them in a bottle to alcohol and get
into the lab and they find out you know
if they've got him here local united
states or they got him in colombia or
you know where those worms came from so
it's all very important information and
so i had access to all that from the
universities and and National Institutes
of Health and Yerkes primate centers and
of course when I did that 1700 autopsies
that project was in Keshawn China and
Milan doctor Milan my wife she's a
medical doctor from China she and her
parents had tremendous connections in
China so she was able to get permission
for me to do two thousand autopsies of
kids in Keshawn China they're all dying
from this heart attack okay and they're
all dying from that deficiency that one
nutrient and I knew that same nutrient
deficiency caused city of roses monster
to be in crib death and so I figured
well they're all arguing with me and
whether it's a genetic disease or not
when the mothers are suffocating the
babies and so what I did was ask her if
she could get me to do 2,000 autopsy if
I could find 10 city of roses kids or
they're supposed to be of European
people you never found sitting abroad
sitting in Chinese or Asians or Japanese
anything like that was all Europeans
that say this it was genetic disease
well I did those 1700 autopsies and
those Chinese kids and Keshawn Province
35% had Ciccio broses mr. Chinese never
paid real attention to that because they
didn't have cystic fibrosis 100 cent had
mustard history they died from Keshawn
disease they died from that heart attack
but they also had mustard history and
then 200 of them
died from what would have been diagnosed
as crib death here in United States
because I won during one year of Aging
and had the the cardiomyopathy heart
attack and so it was a tremendous
project of course I had and when you
look at the publication we lists the I
don't know it had to be eight or ten you
do 1700 autopsies just six weeks okay we
had a team that had to make all the
slides have the team that would come
prepare the bodies and stuff like that I
mean I wasn't taking the bodies out of
the bag and putting them on the table
they would do all that and have that all
arranged so when I came through there
was my job was just to do the autopsy I
didn't have to do the mechanics of
getting the body on the table and take
the body off the table and making the
slides and all that kind of stuff
they had teams that did all that and
that's when I came along said all that
up yeah yeah Yerkes primate Center I
worked there for two years so I mean I
did hundreds of autopsies there and the
University of Missouri I did more than
that one was where the 50 lambs died and
didn't over a thousand there over a
period of four years now probably more
than that it's probably more like four
thousand over four years maybe a
thousand because in some days I'm doing
fifty autopsies you know they bring you
buckets of chickens and things like that
and maybe some laboratory experiment
they'd have a hundred white rats I want
you to do autopsies on you know to
finish out the experiment and that kind
of stuff and so it was you know one
thousand here a thousand there fifty
here
1,700 there twenty thousand there it's
it adds up but very few people have as
much experience in doing the the number
of species I think probably I'm the only
one that has the experience with the
number of species that I've done 454
species maybe probably more than that
but that was at one study I did four
hundred fifty four species of animals in
a big twenty thousand autopsy study and
454 species and plus humans so that's
four fifty five and then
there were other species I think
probably I've done autopsies in over a
thousand species of animals in humans
different races of humans
Asians of all kinds black people of all
kinds Europeans and white people of all
kinds Native Americans and so forth and
that's why my thesis is in the
Smithsonian Institute nobody has done as
much as that as me I'm not probably
smarter than anybody else but nobody has
done this more as many autopsies made
with as much variation usually
somebody's a veterinarian working at the
University they're gonna be a veterinary
pathologist and the animal colony and
they're dealing for 25 years with white
rats and guinea pigs for 25 years okay
and so that's what made my material so
unique and when I could find human
disease that were supposed to be genetic
and animals like mustard this vien
sissie fibrosis and heart disease and
all that kind of stuff it was it was
very obvious that it wasn't genetic it
was a nutritional deficiencies and and
that's why my thesis is in the
Smithsonian Institute they put covers
they put hard covers on the thesis and
sold it as as a textbook WV Saunders
published it which is the biggest
medical
publishing house in the world
WB Saunders and they published that
thesis as a textbook the first printing
was 30,000 the second printing was
30,000 I think we're probably going to
do it again we're gonna have we have a
lot to add to it as you know kind of an
update and refresh it but I think we'll
probably do a hundred thousand copies
this next printing and so we'll probably
do that in the next year or so we're
working on two more books I gotta finish
before we start that project but I think
it's time to update that one but very
very proud of that it started out with
5,000 pages yeah it was 5,000 pages and
everything was very crisp and tight and
Dobby Saunders says we'll never sell him
5,000 pages because you
the book was that dictum there's so much
information there people it would cost
fifty thousand dollars a book they said
I'm not gonna do it
and so they entered it down without
losing any of the meaning all the
pictures were there the pictures stayed
in the microscopic slides and that kind
of stuff
the various diseases where it's
pertinent now if you can find them use
and beat up you might get one for four
hundred bucks but usually they're
averaging around nine hundred to a
thousand dollars if you get them in
pretty good shape they'll sell for forty
five hundred to nine thousand ten
thousand brand-new if they're still in
the box not open they sell for $25,000
because redo that project would cost
over 1 billion dollars they looked at
that a couple of years ago they were
gonna redo the project so I said I'll
volunteer I'll supervise it for nothing
I'd like to redo the project ok thirty
years later so I won't charge anything
I'll just do it just to be doing it and
be involved and they called me in six
months said okay sorry Wallach we can't
do the project and why what's the matter
well we did a an estimate of cost
the project to get it done in ten years
we could cost 1 billion dollars today
there's only 25 million dollars back
then so they'd rather just spend $25,000
on your thesis than to redo it for 1
billion dollars
why don't we talk about tonight is the
biggest cause of death in Americans
cardiovascular disease that sounds
pretty simple but I want to precede
those remarks with two statistics
statistic number one goes back to 2004
the Center for Disease Control some of
you been with me for a while you've
heard that before
Center for Disease Control that
government agency the tracks diseases
and plagues and epidemics and all that
kind of stuff
but they said in 2004 was that our
children would be the first generation
of Americans that do not live as long as
their parents
according to through the Center for
Disease Control that indicates a
catastrophic failure of the healthcare
and medical system the only point in one
direction the health care in the medical
system they are the cause of this where
the government is saying our children
will be the first generation Americans
that do not live as long as their
parents so our goal is to save as many
as we can and we neither build an ark or
we can try and circumvent the problem I
think will help more people by
circumventing the problem just a couple
of years ago Johns Hopkins very famous
medical school from Baltimore Maryland
you've all heard of Johns Hopkins very
famous they came out and said that today
had done they've been looking for 20
years for the top 20 causes of death in
America and that kind of stuff and just
a couple years ago they came out and
said the number three cause of death in
America is medical doctors simple
mistakes in their workplace simple
mistakes in a workplace each year
medical doctors in the workplace kill
250 1000 patients every four years they
kill 1 million patients from simple
mistakes in a workplace how many
businesses could stay in business if
they killed 251 thousands of their
customers every year zero now the reason
they survived is they have insurance so
the insurance pays off the relatives to
keep their mouths shut and their their
society lets them keep their license and
they just keep on going and keep killing
more people now those are two horrible
statistics
I just mean this is in the front page of
the New York Times and yet people
continue to go to doctors I just love my
doctor
he told me take two aspirin a day my
head it could go away cardiovascular
disease is the number one killer of
Americans cardiovascular disease starts
in the intestines would cause you need
nutrients and will get in some of those
nutrients in a minute for the court
vascular system but if you're eating
gluten you cannot absorb them because
you're damaging your intestine and if
you're if your ability to absorb drops
down below 3% no matter how much
supplements you're taking this all going
out in the toilet so part of the deal is
you know for a hundred years the medical
system has been telling everybody eat
more whole grains they're good for you
BAM you're dead because the gluten wheat
bran oat wheat barley rye oats okay now
what was the breakfast of champions why
do you think all the athletes died so
young Wheaties what about Quaker Oats
getting a picture okay now get rid of
all that pancakes waffles you have to
live like an Asian live on rice and
sweet potatoes and vegetables and fish
and poultry and red meats fine but you
can't have wheat brother and oats you
can't eat the European grains if you
like beer that's fine but you got to
drink Japanese Korean and Chinese beer
because they're made from rice all the
European and American beers are made
from wheat this is drop dead serious
problems we're killing our kids by
giving them all these grains vegetarians
kill more people now than communists
then oils which everybody said is good
for you they taste good and salad
dressings and mayo and all that kind of
stuff
don't put mayonnaise on the sandwich
okay because oils oxidize and turn into
trans fats heterocycle means that
acrylamide oils heated oils whether it's
fried or even room-temperature in salads
as a salad dressing cause plaque in your
arteries cholesterol does not cause
plaque in your arteries cholesterol does
not cause heart disease that's an
absolute lie
your biggest enemy is oil turns in a
trans facet or second music relies
found that out and let's see was 1969 I
was on a big project with NIH did my
$20,000 season two of them were wild
sheep from the Atlas Mountains of North
Africa in Arthur Morocco and they were
only in America for two months they died
three days apart when I did the autopsy
on them they died from 90% blockage of
their coronary arteries with plaque I
had to sit down a minute now where were
these sheep getting cholesterol
they're not eating eggs they're not
eating red meat
not eating butter so I gathered up the
food they were eating which was mixed
grains they were giving them grass
clippings from the zoo
they were giving them hey so I got it
all together we look for pollution we
couldn't find any pollution or
contaminants chemical contaminates in
the food but we did find the acrylamide
and the oxidized oils but they didn't in
the recipe they didn't add any oils so
order the heterocycle means and
acrylamide is coming from or the trans
fats you're exactly right
the mixed grain was stored for two years
in a metal 55-gallon drum in a metal
barn and during the summer time to get
over 120 in there and it oxidized the
wheat germ oil and the wheat they were
feeding those those sheep oxidized
turned into trans fats headless I
commute in the coal mines and caused the
plaque in yards I spent six months
researching those things and figured it
out got it published
I tried publishing it in a cardiology
journal here Medical Journal here in
United States it wouldn't take into
wallach you're out of your mind that's a
human disease why would she I said
that's what was my question but I
figured it out no we won't poach it I
couldn't get a person been richer they
say what we called the medical guys
because this is a meta this is a human
disease and they said you're crazy and
we can't publish it so I got to publish
in a Danish pathology journal okay
so it did get published then you have to
appreciate when you can't absorb these
nutrients many of them are minerals now
I have to tell you that hemorrhoids
varicose veins and Angela's
they're caused by deficiency of the same
nutrient that same nutrient deficiency
causes white hair I see some people with
white hair and hearing silver hair and
salt pepper here gray here these are
people who are in great risk of having
aneurysms okay and varicose veins and
hemorrhoids because the that one
nutrient deficient it causes all those
problems then I did 1700 autopsies on
kids under the age of 10 but died of
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease I'd said heart attack that young
athletes died from 1700 autopsies in
that project these kids all died from
this heart disease in America 25,000
under the age of 20 die each year in
America from that sudden heart disease
caused by deficiency of a single mineral
I did that autopsy thing I was actually
looking for something else I already
knew what that was caused by so I was
looking for psittacosis most dystrophy
and sudden death syndrome in the 1700
autopsies of the kids that died of that
heart disease and a heart attack 35
percent had city of roses 100 percent
had moster dystrophy and 200 of them
under the age of 1 year of age had what
would be diagnosed here in America as
crib death or send them to death
syndrome we used that information to sue
the FDA and we got a ruling in our
behalf to put that nutrient in that I've
been trying for years to get all 60
minerals in and they were just too
complicated too complicated this time I
just tried that one nutrient and the
federal judge gave us the ruling in our
favor April 16 2013 but all
manufacturers a baby farmers had to have
that nutrient in it now for up until
that time we actually came up with kids
toddy which had that nutrient in it
which is a liquid multiple for babies
and we'd have them put that in the baby
from this causes the baby formulas only
had three three minerals you need six
sixty all these babies are dying of all
the stuff the doctors are saying oh
they're dying all these genetic diseases
no which is simple mineral deficiencies
so to make a long story short three
months after that ruling by the federal
judge the FDA gave them a high and a low
you can't get below this because you
won't get any result you can't be above
because we don't have an experience
above this and all these manufacturer is
a baby farm list and you know including
things like enfamil Similac why is it
they named baby formula Similac because
it lacks everything but once they put
that nutrient in there three months
later the Charlotte Observer which is
the main newspaper and in Charlotte
North Carolina that came out and said
big headlines in the front page I mean
like third world war type headlines bold
black big headlines said we don't know
why but suddenly man death syndrome has
vanished in North Carolina that's
because they put that Merrill and the
baby fern was three months later the
state of Missouri came out and said the
same thing we don't know why but
sediment death syndrome has vanished in
Missouri it's you're months later every
newspaper in America came out and said
we don't know why but the rate of sudden
infant death syndrome SIDS crib death
has reduced by 85 to 95 percent in every
state because that one nutrient was put
in the formula these are the sort of
things we do so let's get do congestive
heart failure you all heard that that's
caused by deficiency of a single vitamin
and Ryan was interviewing me today and
he's asked me some of these things and
I'd almost forgotten that the porpoises
in captivity we're all dying with
congestive heart failure in the zoo's
and the vector in the 60s I just came
back from Africa they're telling me well
yeah we hit three dolphins for about two
years and they all died of congestive
heart failure another zoo had called me
those are the code they call me from
Europe in London why are all our
dolphins and whales don't even
congestive heart failure
well because it's caused by deficiency
of a single nutrient what turns out the
fish they were feeding them had an
enzyme that destroyed that nutrient
smelt your thenahms smelt it has it has
an enzyme in the muscle at every Jew
that began to feed feed him smelter
cheeping okay and so soon as they all
start having them smelt
they all died of congestive heart
failure yep they did very good you're
okay
so any rate we change your diet got him
on the 90 essential nutrients and it
instantly stopped the deaths in the
dolphins and the whales in the zoos and
so the same thing is
with us one of the things that actually
puts pressure on that vitamin let's say
you're taking a modest amount of that
vitamin if you need a lot of sugar and
sugar in activates your body's ability
to use that vitamin okay it makes that
enzyme that destroys that vitamins
stronger so sugar is one of your worst
enemies when it comes to congestive
heart failure when it comes to birth
defects and babies are born with holes
in their heart and all kinds of heart
problems and this and the other that's
caused by momma missing these nutrients
during pregnancy when the heart is
forming it's not a genetic thing
a-fib a thief is not a hard thing let's
see
cardiologists killed that congressman
from Roger Coleman Elijah Cummings where
he was from
Maryland yeah okay logic Cummings he was
68 years old he been in the Congress for
what 30 years or 40 years of some
longtime congressman he had afib and
they opened him up and they took a
soldering iron heated up and trying to
killing parts of his heart muscles so
that wouldn't run fast and eat you
regularly so they thought it was a heart
problem they killed him on this on the
surgery table a congressman they killed
him with the wrong treatment because he
had a back problem the nerves of control
rate and rhythm of heart are the first
four thoracic spinal nerves
we have degenerative disc disease your
vertebrae T 1 2 3 & 4 get closer
together and smash the roots of those
nerves causing afib now also if you have
osteoporosis of the skull and is
squeezing the tenth cranial nerve the
vagus nerve vagus nerve does many things
when when you squeeze the vagus nerve
you get COPD at chronic dry cough
unproductive cough that's osteoporosis
is called squeezing the 10th scrander of
the vagus nerve you also get a fib so
you can have a fib from osteoporosis of
the skull squeezing the tenth cranial
nerve and also from degenerative disc
disease squeezing those foreigners
between T 1 2 3 & 4 so you can have two
causes of afib but none of them are from
the heart also you can have what's
called gastroparesis
the extremely painful belly pain and
they can't figure it out but it turns
out it's that vagus nerve goes all the
way down into your belly and controls
your intestine
in your stomach and they'll put these
endoscopic tubes down your throat and
look around they're looking for an ulcer
that kind of stuff or cancer your
stomach take samples and things they
can't figure it out so well the only way
we can guarantee we can take away the
pain we'll just take your stomach out
that's the wrong approach right and so
I'm telling you all this
oh there's one other thing had to back
up I missed one okay how many of you
hurt red blood cells your white blood
cells never heard of platelets okay all
of those are part of the cardiovascular
system right they're just the mobile
cells that carry oxygen and food and
stuff like that right
they do things but they require 90
essential nutrients your bone marrow
makes red blood cells white blood cells
and platelets so your bone marrow is
part of your cardiovascular system
because if you're not giving all the
nutrients necessary to your bone marrow
you can't make red blood cells white
blood cells and platelets because I oh
you have an autoimmune disease your
platelets aren't there anymore really do
you have any skin pumps yeah I've got
eczema and dermatitis well mark see what
does that mean gluten alert gluten alert
gluten alert so even if you're
supplementing with minerals you can't
absorb them so your bone marrow still
without the minerals okay well what
about white blood cells huh you know
what if you get a you know on the moment
or something like that your white blood
cells go up they say no they can't
figure out why is they say must have a
bad genetics for my immune system
because I can I can get any disease you
can think of and my my blood cells never
pay attention never increase or never go
to the local place I have nothing okay
well when you bleed how long people if
I'd Nick myself shaving I'm bleeding for
three days that's because there's no
platelets because the bone marrow is not
getting the nutrients in these because
you're on gluten and it can't absorb me
if you're supplementing and you know
people with these problems you know you
put the piece of tissue paper in their
face and just bleeding through that all
the time you know your platelets aren't
working so all that has to do with the
cardiovascular system the doctors won't
you think it's just your heart and
arteries how many nutrients does it take
for bone marrow to make red blood cells
in 90
oh my doctors said I just needed iron
for my red blood cells no you have all
the
proper amounts of iron in your blood but
if you're missing any one of the other
89 you're gonna be anemic well my doctor
says I have a genetic disease
well what about sickle-cell anemia it's
called thalassemia called thalassemia
and white folks same disease because
it's not a genetic problem in black
people I've seen sickle-cell anemia and
hummingbirds okay and snakes all kinds
of vertebrates of every kind chickens
and all kinds of stuff why because it's
the deficiency of a single nutrient
during incubation and the egg are during
gestation and the uterus when this when
the bone marrow cells are farming that
make hemoglobin and Mama's missing that
stuff there's an injury and so it just
keeps producing dysfunctional red blood
cells doesn't matter what race you are
what species you are so the
cardiovascular system is a lot more
complicated than just you know doing a
heart transplant and you guys are in a
position to prevent all these problems
and reverse all these problems now you
think about that
remember the CDC says our kids will be
the first generation of Americans that
do not live as long as their parents
that's because doctors are giving out
nothing but misinformation eat more
whole grains it's the worst possible
thing you can do eat like an Asian rice
and sweet potatoes vegetables fish
except for smelt okay and poultry is
fine red means fine but you can't fry it
you can't burn it but just I took iron
no you need everything to make it all
work because you're dealing with every
tissue in the body is part of the court
master system so let's open up for
questions a few questions yes sir
3 3 snack foods alcohol peanuts raisins
sunflower curls in a wild blueberry
that's four that's four okay any of them
good bad what's the well you said some
thoris ease right sunflower kernels
kernels okay
well you got to watch it because they
have oil in them sunflower oil they're
stored for any length of time they've
oxidized and turned into bad stuff same
with peanuts oils or ginger yeah oils
are dangerous they cause cancer and they
caused plaque in your arteries also
peanuts have a fun
this on him well aflatoxin Ryan and I
were talking about that today when he
was filming me and there was a very
famous story goes back to the 60s and
all the bears in the world in captivity
were dying a liver cancer every bear in
the world in captivity was dying of
liver cancer
polar bears black bears Kodiak bears
brown bears Sun bears pandas they were
all dying of liver cancer when I came
back from Africa to do my 20000 autopsy
study for Marlon Perkins and an NIH he
gave me his personal list okay you're
gonna do the project for NIH but since I
got you the grant these are the 12
things I won well the first thing on
there was all the bears in captivity or
dying of liver cancer okay well it's not
as unit within here so well what do they
think it is he said well they just say
it's got to be a genetic thing in bears
why suddenly after all these years are
every bear of every species angular
cancer it can't be genetic so don't tell
me to net it okay so what are they
feeding them well they're just you know
give them vegetables and bread and
peanuts and stuff you know stuff like
that and I know they sell peanuts and
people throw peanuts ooh and they stand
up and beg and people throw peanuts to
them and kind of stuff well there's a
fungus that grows on peanuts called
Aspergillus which produces a toxin
called aflatoxin which causes liver
cancer
there is a mold that grows on bread you
know this people call it penicillin mold
but it's really not penicillin mold it's
actually the sands for Djilas it's kind
of green like penicillin but it's not as
for Djilas so they're also getting from
the from the old moldy bread which they
would buy for 25 cents a loaf and feed
it to the Bears goes one low for about
1,500 calories and they didn't have to
give them all that meat and this and the
other so they're just give them two
three loaves a per bear every day moldy
bread Senate rate so he said okay let's
write a letter
so all these is because I mean we're
talking 1960 we didn't have emails and
stuff like this let's write a letter all
the zoos and suggesting that this is the
problem and just have them change the
dog food there's gluten-free
okay had the gluten-free dog for dry dog
food and vegetables and let's see what
happens when ninety days
all of the deaths from liver cancer has
stopped and there never been another
bear since the 1960s get liver cancer
ever since so we save the Dolphins by
changing their diet we saved the Bears
by seeing their diet okay what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna find out from the
medical school there in New York City I
want them to give me honey what
percentage is in the homeless people
dying of liver cancer versus people
people who are in the middle class dying
of liver cancer I'll bet you the
homeless people is many times higher
because they're eating the old moldy
bread is it aflatoxin and the
Aspergillus mold these are things you
can control and they're all in the books
are all in the book rare earths man
cures epigenetics that's all in the book
dead doctors don't lie it's in the book
and mortality that stuff is in there
there's life-saving stuff in there yeah
you know I forget about these things and
forget
oh we were going over how many autopsies
they've done and I I'm missing about
4,000 I so did I do those and we're
driving over here and it dawned on me I
spent two years in Africa and the impala
antelope were competing with the white
rhino for the same shark grass and we're
killing 400 of them to 500 a month so
they wouldn't be eating the stuff that
the white rhino needed and we would give
the meat to all the local villages so
they were happy was against the law for
them to hunt him but we could crop them
to say save the white rhino so I did
autopsies and every one of them I mean
we didn't do laboratory work without in
the middle of bush but we did gross
autopsies on all of them now which one's
had birth defects for they have birth
defects out in the wild because it's not
a genetic thing it's a nutritional
deficiencies parasites this sort of
things and intestines you know you get a
round worm that long it's easy to see
you don't need to look under a
microscope to find that one and so forth
and so that was another four thousand
there 1,700 in China 20,000 in North
America
okay the universities another five
thousand between University Missouri
Iowa State University Washington
University and and also the Yerkes
primate Center in Atlanta worked for
NASA yeah I get almost breathless when
you think about all the things we've
done to help save humanity and of course
the medical doctors say just the
opposite the auto listen that Wallach
he's a quack blah blah blah okay
and so people choose poorly and they'll
listen to their doctor and the doctor
will kill him okay anybody else have a
question yes okay have you ever heard of
crap all the science crap oh yeah crap
hold on yes what is it what does GMOs
stand for okay see now they're trying to
blame all these illnesses on genetically
modified food that's crap oh Lola okay
it has nothing to do with that they have
to appreciate that mineral nutrients
which make up two-thirds of the 90
essential nutrients we need do not occur
in a uniform blanket around the cross a
year if they occur in veins like
chocolate chocolate ice cream they occur
like gold and gold mines does gold cover
the earth equally no there's a mine over
here ten thousand miles her wasn't mine
over there same it was cold same where
the oil fields saying was silver same
way with iron they do not occur in a
uniform blanket around the cross the
earth I was able to prove after 20,000
autopsies in one project that there are
no genetically transmitted diseases
there are no Jackie transmitted birth
defects and so when when doctors
couldn't figure out and the
environmentalist couldn't figure out why
we're having all these problems well
they're gonna blame it on GMOs it's a
genetically modified thing well that's
why we're having all these problems no
none of it is caused by GMOs I get
breathless every time I think about this
how badly they missed it there are
children be the first generation of
Americans that don't live as long as
their parents doctors kill in their
workplace by simple mistakes every year
250 1,000
when do you say enough is enough now we
have to take control and that's what
you're seeing with youngevity people
need and want the information you have
to be independent back when I was a kid
we didn't have electricity I was nine
years old in those days all the grantees
use wood stoves they didn't have
electric stoves and when Grandma had
cravings hit Paikea and cravings are you
pregnant you have cravings no I just
have cravings she take a spoon go out in
the backyard and eat clay and dirt kids
will eat dirt when they have cravings
they would use wood ashes they eat wood
ashes and they'd mix them in with their
porridge or they put them in their
drinks or that they put them in their
bread dough to stop the cravings would
ashes which are minerals now babies what
was what were the what were the beds
called for babies 50 150 years ago
cribs how many were heard of cribbing
okay babies would chew on the rail of
the cribs when they were missing those
minerals and have cravings and so they
started putting fiberglass and plastic
shields on the rails to prevent cribbing
now when you go into a horse barn and
you see what the horses are chewing on
the top rail of the stall they're in
they call it what cribbing
well Pike is another name cribbing is
the common term for it is caused by
mineral deficiencies now why is it
I'll find out here pretty soon in Santa
Monica and California it had 28 horses
either died on the track or had to be
destroyed because they broke legs racing
on the track let me heard about that
kind of thing going on yeah it didn't
happen before why is it happening now
well I'll bet you they changed their
source of mineral supplements or maybe
is to save a little money they stopped
giving a mineral sometimes they just
given them hay in Grain well there was a
gluten in grain and hay which only needs
three minerals and so on the first thing
I'm gonna do is go in the barns and see
if they're tripping and then I'm gonna
get a hair from their mane and tail and
do hair analysis on them
and I'm gonna I'm sure they did
autopsies on him so I'll you know go to
the venturi school and get the results
of the autopsy okay very good
minerals very high levels and minerals
because cravings are tied to nutritional
deficiencies okay and of course why did
they take them originally do they have
anxiety do they have depression okay
anxiety okay well anxiety is caused by a
mineral deficiency caused by deficiency
of a single mineral talk therapy and all
the tranquilizers and painkillers in the
world aren't going to fix it because
it's a mineral deficiency and then you
get rid of all the gluten and all the
bad stuff right and you have to
appreciate all these people that have
done mass murders and mass shootings all
these people who do terrible things of
their family and their schoolmates and
workmates in public places all these
people who right now have autism and all
the various symptoms of autism we have 1
million kids under the age of 6 that are
already on psychotropic drugs for autism
in America 1 million right now under the
age of 6 and if everybody if you have
someone in your family with a DD ADHD
autism anxiety you get them on the
minerals get them on the 90 essential
nutrients talk therapy and tranquilizers
aren't going to cut it and I'll end that
statement was I mean you really need to
which they say you really need to listen
to some of my presentations because go
into this in great detail but this was
the one that I want to share with you is
a medical doctor from South Bend Indiana
in September of last year he was late he
been practicing for 40 years in Indiana
had four clinics people loved him he
didn't show up for a family meeting so
they sent his son to go to his house in
Illinois and sure enough he was dead
from a heart attack 70 years old
Ulric George Klopfer is his name ciello
P fer well after they buried him a week
later you know the insurance had paid
off and they had the household and they
everybody met at his house all the
family to met there to divide up the
insurance money and sell the house and
get that money buy it
cars and furniture all that kind of
stuff one sons exploring the basement in
the six car garage in the Attic and he
finds he finds 2400 medically embalmed
human bodies in blue plastic bags 2400
no I guarantee he was deficient in
nutrients so this is a very simple
problem okay well one thank you all god
bless you we have a job to do to save
America youngevity is in a position to
save America and I'm very excited about
this save as many as you can in your
church and your family and your
neighbors your workplace and that's what
it's gonna take
and don't forget we have tools people
one of their heaviest questions people
ask me is I'd like to do this but I'm
not a nurse I'm not a doctor I'm not a
pharmacist people gonna be asked me
about diabetes and arthritis and Alan's
heart disease and all this kind of stuff
what do we do and what do I do well we
have tools we have CDs DVDs and books to
tell you what to do we have these kind
of meetings and these people have been
with me Sharan margie been with me for
what 29 years yeah almost 30 years and
they know more than doctors okay we have
people been with Lance how long you been
with me 17 years okay there you go
well let me start out by saying that all
birth defects are preventable there's a
small percentage of birth defects that
are caused by infections with viruses
and bacteria and fungus and poisons and
pharmaceuticals in the early stages of
pregnancy one of the most famous ones is
solidified which was a Australian drug
for morning sickness and women in early
pregnancies and 10,000 babies in America
were born without arms and legs because
thalidomide interrupted the development
of the limbs and the early embryo all
other birth defects are caused by a
nutritional deficiencies in the
developmental stage of the embryo there
are no gently transmitted birth defects
my thesis $25,000,000 study of the
National Institutes of Health is in the
Smithsonian Institute as a national
treasure because I found there were no
gently transmitted birth defects and
there are no gently transmitted diseases
when it comes specifically to Down
syndrome Down syndrome
obviously is caused by birth defect at
the moment of the first duplication in
other words when the sperm fertilizes
the egg er one celled human being and
then that one celled human being divides
into two cells at that moment if you're
deficient in one particular mineral the
odds being a Down syndrome is very high
and of course up until the second month
of pregnancy
I have success in reversing Down
syndrome embryos by giving them other
than 90 essential nutrients to provide
that nutrient and other nutrients of
course and we've done this in animals
we've done it in people my most famous
one was Lauren Knievel Evel Knievel's
niece-in-law she came to me she was two
and a half months pregnant and diagnosed
for the Down syndrome embryo and she
says well I'm not going to get a a
abortion and I know I'm kind of late
along the line here but can you help me
I said well yeah I think you know we'll
give it a shot but you know I can't give
any guarantees because I've never done
one past two months so in other words we
gave her the 90 essential nutrients her
baby's born perfectly normal of course
it was a famous story because as Lauren
Knievel and Evel Knievel were very
famous people but the same thing is true
with all birth defects where there was a
two and three headed baby or it's a baby
with a heart defect or hydron cephalus
heel which is spina bifida the brain
that kind of thing we have kids we're on
too many fingers no arms we have kids
barn with mustard he says he roses all
these kind of things these are all
totally preventable City cryptosystem
much mystery reversible even after the
baby's born because their nutritional
deficiencies they're not genetic defects
obviously when a baby's born without an
arm you can't give him vitamins minerals
in Rico or arm but this information
should be taught in sixth grade about
the time that teenagers are going
through puberty there should be very
heavily if you take the 90 essential
nutrients you can prevent almost all
birth defects except the ones caused by
viruses and chemicals and prescription
drugs and so forth and it'll give
everybody's babies grandbabies the best
shot at being born normal
and whether they have a cleft palate or
a cleft lip and of course they have a
very famous story about that the ones
who had a pair of arctic foxes and they
had a litter of babies in ten of them
and they were all born with cleft palate
and of course the general curator and
all keepers wanted to destroy the mother
and father and all the babies because
they were afraid it was a genetic
problem whoa
before you do that let's do something
useful here first of all what did you
feed the mother and father before they
got pregnant well they're meat eaters so
he gave them horse meat okay did you get
many vitamins minerals no other
meat-eaters we gave him horse meat well
that's why the babies were born with all
with cleft palates and cleft lip because
mom was missing things when the baby
went from a flat disc into a tube okay
and they had a cleft palate cleft lip
and that's that's the cause so I'm gonna
prove it to you so what I want you to do
is take two or the males and to the
females and I want you to hand raise
them and bottle feed them and I want you
to keep them separate and then when
they're old enough to go through puberty
breed one of the males to one female you
know to a sister I mean that's an umber
inbreeding as much as you get
and breathe the other female to the
brother yes inbreeding again but I want
you to give them dog food and I want you
to give them dog puppy formula and hand
feed them the formula with all the
nutrients in it prior to them getting
old enough to be pregnant the others
that you keep I want you to let the
father of these babies breed to other
females or two to four of the female
babies but you've got to have to the
same way hand raised those with the
puppy formula well the nutrients in it
and then when they get old enough you're
gonna give them dog food okay it has to
be gluten-free dog physic maximize
absorption of nutrients and then I want
to mail babies to get old enough to be
able to breed the mother and and get her
pregnant inbreeding again and let's see
how many of the babies are born with
cleft palate now if it's if its genetic
I mean this can be a hundred percent
babies with cleft palate because you're
inbreeding and inbreeding and inbreeding
and so it should be 100 percent cleft
palate so we did that and nine months
later we totally had a hundred babies
from all those inbreeding couples and
pairs they're all born perfectly normal
published the big detail is in the book
rare earths are been cures I would say
that's the place to see it is there's
actually the picture in there of all
those kits with the cleft palates and
cleft lips and then you get all the
statistics and everything is so this is
true of all other birth defects
cycloptic babies one eyes in the middle
of four head-to-heads babies we're
talking about heart defects and we're
talking about babies born with every
kind of physical defects you can think
of or biochemical defects you can think
of they're all nutritional deficiencies
during the development developmental
stage of the embryo totally 100%
preventable totally 100% preventable and
this should be the responsibility of
fifth and sixth grade science teachers
pediatricians OBGYNs the government
schools universities in medical school
really this is medical students you get
taught this nursing school where the
nursing students schools get taught this
and also in these schools where people
get trained to be dietitians and
nutritionists we can eliminate all birth
defects none of them are genetic okay
down syndrome occurs in animals Down
syndrome occurs in every race of human
beings
it occurs in every type of vertebrates
because it's a deficiency of one
particular nutrient when the baby goes
from one celled embryo to a two cell
embryo and so this is a critical moment
for that baby but if you give them the
nutrients as they're you know kinda like
two-thirds of the way through incubation
in eggs or gestation in uterus you can
reverse the Down syndrome situation
because we've done it many many times
including again Loren Knievel so it
doesn't matter the species if you're a
vertebrae of any species you have that
deficiency at that stage where you're
going from a one-celled human being to a
two cell of human being there's a
possibility of being a Down syndrome
baby regardless of species and you have
to appreciate that rickets are
preventable by supplementing with
vitamin d3 now that doesn't mean that
some kid that has rickets doesn't mean
that there are less of a human being
because we've learned how to prevent
rickets by giving all people's before
during pregnancy after pregnancy the 90
essential nutrients which includes
vitamin d3 and prevents rickets it
doesn't mean there's something bad about
the kid with rickets they're probably
not going to be a track star and if
they're young enough with rickets if
they're just a couple years old and have
rickets you can reverse the rickets and
of course I have a very famous story
about the Down syndrome with Ben and
Wendy which I think in earlier
interviews we've discussed that but
wouldn't hurt to mention them briefly
again forty years ago Ben what Wendy
were born in Texas in different cities
they didn't know each other their
families didn't know each other she was
born with Down syndrome
he was barman down syndrome over time
their family is because the jobs and
things move closer together and
20-something years ago they met each
other became good friends I should tell
you that when they were born in each
case they were living in a town which we
had a youngevity associate okay Bob and
Judy and they were giving the parents
the 90 essential nutrients to give
either directly or indirectly to those
babies after they were born and had been
diagnosed with Down syndrome and so they
were getting the United centenarians
from the day they were born
it's one with being breastfed mama was
taking the nine essential nutrients the
other was getting a bottle formula of
getting the kids toddy with that
nutrient plus extra nutrients 16 years
ago now in September of last year of 16
years I was the best man at their
wedding they got married and so this is
the 16th year and they're celebrating
their 16th wedding anniversary and if
you look at them you have to really look
hard you really have to know what you're
looking at to see that they're Down
syndrome because a state on those
Dinah's central nutrients or whole life
and at that same time we were
celebrating their 16th wedding
anniversary and I had been the best man
at their wedding I danced with the bride
we have a film with me dancing with a
bride 16 years ago Ben is retiring from
his job after 25 years with Texas A&M
and he was the head of one part of a
computer department in the engineering
department the engineering school of
Texas A&M so he was as smart as you can
get for a human being because he was
taking the nutrients to make and eating
all the right things eating 4 eggs 3
times a day in the same way from all the
bad stuff so it can absorb and Wendy she
is still working for chick-fil-a as an
international director of advertising
these are jobs require a lot of
brainpower these are jobs that require
the ability to make decisions of great
cost and value and importance and they
did it with great skill even though they
were born dumb syndrome babies that's
because they avoided the bad foods and
they took the 90 essential nutrients and
ate properly and gave their brain
maximum nutrition max
Supplement approach to function and
there a classic example of the fact that
Down syndrome babies can be supported
nutritionally and participate in very
high-end jobs whether it's a university
with some technology whether it's in
private industry and so just because we
say we can prevent down syndrome babies
just because we can support Down
syndrome babies doesn't mean we are
dissing our seeing anything really
negative about those babies they're
victims and so somebody along the line
should be held responsible for that
because it was totally preventable early
on if they took the 90 essential
nutrients stay away from the bad stuff
they could participate in advanced high
tech society and in a very very
productive way so you know when people
say oh we're dissing somebody some kids
with Down syndrome by saying you can
prevent it no no that absolutely not
that is definitely an incorrect view in
your own fingernails so we go from Down
syndrome and your own fingernails okay I
mean you have ingrown fingernails we're
talking about we're talking about skin
issues we're talking about cuticle
issues we're talking about the raw
materials to make healthy skin healthy
connective tissue and healthy nails so
it always comes down to they've got to
get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no process means no oils or
glutens know we brought around knows no
sugar and they need the 90 essential
nutrients and with that it's telling you
they've got a connective tissue problem
so I need to add to I'd go with the
biggest tool we have in our toolbox
because it's kind of an early signal
there's things going wrong and then of
course they need to keep their nails
clipped properly and so the pressure is
not put in the wrong place and and it's
if they need to they need to go to a one
of these places that do toenails and
fingernails medically and so forth and
keep them trimmed properly and in a
period of three to six months everything
will come right because this is a
dynamic thing your skin is dynamic your
nail beds whether your toes your fingers
or dynamics are constantly degrading are
increasing in health depending on their
nutritional flow and blood supply and
so forth but asthma has was due to a
deficiency of a single class of
nutrients almost always it indicates
that this person has been very naughty
and eating lots of gluten because
there's one nutrient is a very big
clumsy molecule very big clumsy molecule
and it's one of the first things you
cannot absorb efficiently when you have
a gluten problem it's one of the first
things ago and these same people who
have asthma usually wind up with eczema
dermatitis psoriasis rosacea and they
will be diagnosed with things like lupus
they'll be diagnosed with fibromyalgia
I've had one child a pastor creflo
dollar's daughter she was 11 and a half
years old and she was diagnosed with
asthma and Emory University in Atlanta
Georgia told pastor dollar that she was
born with a genetic form of asthma and
she was gonna die within a year so she
was not gonna live to be 12
she's 11 a half years of old as if he's
gonna die before 12 because she's having
like 10 crises these a day or asthma and
they're barely able to save her and a
few times by giving her the medication
and so Andy young Andrew Young from the
old Civil Rights Movement he and pastor
dollar called me now this no we're
talking 30 years ago a very famous is
mayor of Atlanta
very famous very wonderful man the
Andrew Young well Andrew young it was a
mayor of Atlanta mm-hmm and he has part
of dr. King's army and of course for the
wonderful movement to free everybody
right Andy Young was the guy who brought
pastor dollar to me
and so I said look there is no such
thing as a genetic form of any disease
and your daughter has very simple
nutritional deficiency and if you get on
a gear on a specific diet everybody the
households gonna do the same thing
there's no cross-contamination in the
washer and the dryer and their food
preparation services and the beds and
the couches everybody's got to be on the
same diet and then she needs to be on
the 90 essential nutrient for her body
weight and I believe we can save her and
very quickly get rid of her asthma and
her other symptoms of this problem well
Emory University said and they said well
they're incorrect they're wrong
so you have two choices you can follow
what they say let her have candy and
stay up all night and walk
TV and eat and whatever she wants and
whether she wants and she will die
before she's 12 as they say but if you
could change the diet in the household
get her on the proper diet give her the
90 essential nutrients within weeks her
asthma will go away and she will give
you grandchildren so you have to decide
which route you're gonna take and they
put their hand over the phone under her
going she sort of thing came back on and
pastor dollar said okay I think we're
gonna try what you're doing yeah you can
still pray for her there's no you know
God's medicine is the strongest medicine
so do what you can do for that end and
then of course the nutrition and the die
and so forth they just call me every two
weeks and let me know how she's doing
and he dutifully called me in two weeks
and said two words
she's cure was the way he said it to me
he streamed it to me over the phone two
words and 20 years later it made her do
something she'd give him grandchildren
beautiful I have a picture of he and her
when she's 30 years old
and she is supposed to die at age 12 so
there are no gently transmitted diseases
there are no gently transmitted birth
defects is that simple there's a bunch
more questions here concussion
okay well obviously concussion can
happen from falling down the stairs me
and the car accident being hit in the
head with a baseball I mean there's all
kinds of ways you can get a concussion
and you get a demon swelling maybe even
some bleeding inside the skull so you're
getting pressure inside the head so you
need to get rid of the pressure inside
the head as well as relieve inflammation
and so forth that's already transpired
so when you have concussion in the head
I like to again use the biggest hammer
in the toolbox get rid of all the bad
foods use a healthy brain and heart pack
eat three or four eggs twice a day per
100 pounds of body weight with soft
yolks need to have what we call few
Cloyd z which is an anti-inflammatory
take three of those twice a day 400
pounds of body weight I'd also take the
synaptic so the brain cells can
communicate with each other we need to
give them the ultimate daily classic
to get proper blood flow into the brain
and proper exit of blood from the brain
to carry off the edema and swelling in
the brain and we do have the what we
call relax which is an anti-inflammatory
sedative for the brain is from our hemp
FX as a CBD oh I was about a half a
dozen other herbs added to the pre
hormone added to it to relieve anxiety
and things going on in the brain and to
relieve the inability to sleep which
happens when you have a concussion and
so forth allows an encouraging sleep and
rest and of course then we have the
soothe soo th e and trauma while from
aromatherapy oil division it's a blend
of aromatherapy oils that actually
relieve inflammation this I put four or
five drops of the trauma while tra um a
into a teaspoon of this su the soo th e
mix set up really good and put it behind
the ears put it in the ears put on the
back of the neck put on top of the head
they replace you can on the skull to
encourage reduction of inflammation and
swelling could you speak a little bit on
the reaction that the medical system has
had to you especially since 1978 mold
cystic fibrosis story has some of the
reactions and Wyatt as the medical
establishment disregarded all all the
successes and natural medicines and
nutrition welcome we have to appreciate
why doctors said there were gently
transmitted diseases but they didn't
know an answer to the cause of a disease
the treatment of disease they would say
well you have bad genes because they
wouldn't want to say well you know I
have no earthly idea what's going on
here we can try and treat some of the
symptoms but I can't guarantee a cure
because I don't know what's going on
they're not going to do that they say
well you have bad genes and that's why
you have this problem and I might be
able to treat some of the symptoms but I
can't deal with this it causes your
bodies in a bad situation because of bad
genes and that got started you know over
a hundred years ago when the Annis -
there were genes for you for hair color
eye color skin color that kind of
and so they began to say well those
jeans do weird things and cause we're
diseases and so the first one that I
came up with which I showed very clearly
that it was a non-native Jasmine disease
was City grossest I was working at the
Yerkes primate Center for Emory
University and NASA and as a pathologist
and a clinician and I discovered the
first non-human case of City Kerberos in
a NASA monkey headed for space it was
six months old and it was in a colony of
25 baby monkeys was one of 25 they're
all about the same age
every baby monkey had a different mother
and father which were not related as
cousins or brothers and sisters so they
weren't related in any way genetically
except that they were monkeys check out
permission because I actually had sent
out slides of these tissues and I to
experts in sincere erosive pathogens I
think this is what do you think they'd
send me back a letter saying all of them
from all these big universities and
medical schools oh no doubt about it
this is a classic example of 60
Barbarossa's well then away I call them
up said well hey thank you for
confirming in writing as this mitosis
this slide came from a baby monkey you
have reconfirmed what I thought this is
the first non-human case of cirrhosis
and now we're going to be able to be
able to have animal colonies with
cirrhosis instead of the disease and do
good things for these kids and a very
rapid rate and everybody's excited I was
literally in every newspaper in the
world every day for three months until I
got permission to do biopsies and the
other 24 baby monkeys so I did the
biopsies in their their lungs and their
livers and kidneys sure enough they all
had cirrhosis they weren't related to
each other genetically in any way shape
or form so I got it all written up for
publication and got you know I said I
submitted for to the University Emory
University the Medical School to get
permission to start building this as a
colony of baby monkeys so we could study
how to prevent and reverse psittacosis
because I had proved now that it was not
genetic and they fired me that's a
pretty strong reaction
they fired machine oh wait a minute
we've got all the blood we've got the
baby monkeys so alive we've got all the
other baby
monkeys have been diagnosed microscope
you know through biopsies and you can
redo everything yourself say well we're
not arguing with the results of the
microscopic studies in the blood tests
and everything but to say this is not a
genetic thing we are argue about that
I said well you look at it give me six
months and I'll give you a thousand
maybe monkeys with cerebro says we can
really study this no you're fired well
that's what drove me to realize how bad
the medical science was okay now jump
forward a little bit and remind you that
the Center for Disease Control came out
in 2004 and said that our children our
children will be the first generation of
Americans that do not live as long as
their parents that's because the medical
system treats diseases they don't know
anything about as a genetic disease and
just treat symptoms as opposed to
getting rid of the disease even though
in animal industry we've gotten rid of
the disease even though I've used the
animal approach to treating these people
this disease and gotten rid of the
disease in fact it did the same thing
with mustard history and gave Jerry
Lewis dozens and dozens of charts of
kids that had come to me with mustard
history gave them the treatment for
mustard history which is called white
muscle disease and animals and show that
they could be reversed and made normal
it wasn't a genetic disease he got so
excited he took all these charts and
tables to the muster dystrophy
association they immediately fired Jerry
Lewis and shut down the telethon with
Jerry Lewis had been doing for 20 years
to raise money for the research we had
notice in the past ten years you haven't
heard much about grosses you
haven't heard much about much rucifee
you haven't heard much about son-of-a
death syndrome because by putting these
nutrients into the baby formulas by
court order by federal court order power
that the baby formulas did not have
these nutrients in it and the babies
were dying the nutritional deficiencies
doctors are saying they were a genetic
problem we've eliminated hundreds and
hundreds of different diseases and
babies and you know three months after
the court's ruling on putting the
nutrient in the baby formula front-page
story
big story Charlotte Observer we don't
know why but sending medicinal has
vanished in North Carolina
Sherman's later the state of Missouri
said the same thing we don't know why
but sentiment death syndrome has
vanished in Missouri then three months
later totally nine months after the
court ruling every state came out and
said we don't know why but the rate of
sentiment death syndrome has dropped by
eighty five to ninety five percent now
when you look at the statistics only two
percent of the babies that died of what
would be diagnosed as sentiment death
syndrome were in bed with her mother
when they died the rest Emmer said that
they suffocated in the blankets well I
read did a lot of those autopsies in
guarentee ax
they died a hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
heart disease they didn't die from
suffocation and their blankets there's
because doctors didn't know what was
causing it they thought the baby for
others were perfect that's why all those
babies were dying of sudden death
syndrome in getting muster dystrophy and
getting city of roses and having asthma
and all this kind of stuff because of
the lack of nutrition in the lack of
absorption when you went around and told
the cystic fibrosis story and how are
you were fired for discovering the cause
care prevention in Cisco fibrosis and
rhesus monkeys what was the reaction
well in the general public they were
just very angry with the scientific
community and I realized that I was
going to have to do something more than
just tell the story because then it was
then left to the devices of people to go
do their thing and first the thing they
do they say well well I went to my
doctor and told him your story and they
just laughed and it's on that Wallach is
a quack he don't know what he's talking
about looking all the medical textbooks
it's a genetic disease and so that's why
I started coming out with CDs and DVDs
and books started lecturing all over the
place
make a long story short I bought a 20
year old clinic before two years before
I graduated as a doctor and doctors
would legally run it with their licenses
and I began to work there and do my
residency my own clinic and and two
years I got my degrees and licenses and
so forth and began to work at my own
clinic but not only did I carry on with
the patients that they had I started
putting on free meetings every Tuesday
and Thursday night at the clinic I ever
ties on the radio
paid $300 for a 30-second ad to come to
this clinic and get a free health
lecture ask all the questions one about
any disease you want and so
I began to get 300 people on a throne
Tuesday night into Thursday night coming
to my free lectures most nature pelvic
physicians even licensed in Oregon where
I started out they'd see 15 patients a
day and there all were joy well today
because of information and 9 languages
audio cassette tapes CDs DVDs books I
see 2 million patients a day in 50
countries and because of all the tools I
have literally hundreds of thousands and
even millions of people who will give
the same answer to a question that I
would give that's what makes us
different that we can treat prevent and
reverse 900 different diseases using
nutrition using diet but you cannot get
everything you need just by eating well
that's also misinformation you must
supplement plans only need three
elements from us all to make good seeds
for the next generation we need 60 so
you could be 57 short you must
supplement to get everything you need
and people will say oh people didn't
supplement 100 200 300 500 years ago oh
yeah they did they put wood ashes from
their wood stoves into the gardens if
they had cravings they'd put wood ashes
into their breakfast porridge our into
the bread dough grandma would go out in
the backyard with a spoon eat dirt when
she had cravings
well dirts minerals ashes are minerals
and that's how people got their minerals
people did supplement my grandmother
lived 112 well you're not gonna live to
be a hundred and twelve if you don't
supplement because she was supplementing
by putting her wood ashes into the
garden and she lived in a place that had
lots of minerals in the soil trees only
need three elements from the soil to
make good seeds from the next generation
well guess what if you just you know if
you just eat things cooked on
electricity and those bell peppers the
squash were growing on sell that only
had three nutrients in it that's the
fertilizer the commercial fertilizer NPK
you're gonna get all kinds of diseases
cuz you're only getting NPK plants
cannot make minerals we require sixty
minerals I've been at a bunch of your
talks where and you always ask is there
any medical professionals in the
audience and usually you get some nurses
and maybe maybe a chiropractor and
sometimes there's a medical doctor in
the audience I personally sat there with
a great curiosity waiting for the
medical doctors question
and many times I've seen them walk out
halfway or right before the QA or they
just sit there and they don't answer
they don't ask a question so I have not
actually seen that many reactions to you
from medical doctors because they seem
to just walk away from it what are some
of the reactions that you have gotten
from doctors other than just ignoring
you
well the strongest reactions of course
occurred 20 30 40 years ago we've been
around a long time been on the radio for
25 years and thirteen hundred and
fifty-eight radio stations I do
interviews with very famous talk-show
hosts like Alex Jones and George Noory
and people like that so it's not like I
have them in around it's not like
doctors haven't heard me before and so
if they do come there they just want to
see how many people are showing up they
want to see if any of their patients are
there is really why they're there you're
not coming to learn anything from me the
strongest reaction ever had this gosh
has got to be 25 30 years ago the first
question during the Q&A was from a 30
year old person who said my mom has
major degeneration she's been legally
blind for eight years is there anything
he can do to help her yeah I can reverse
that this guy jumps up in the back of
the room said well like you're a GD liar
well who are you he said well I'm a
medical doctor I'm an eye doctor and
that's all I do see patients who are
blind I see patients by the hundreds
every year who have been blind six eight
ten years because they have macular
degeneration it's a disease of Aging and
you can't prevent it there's a disease
of aging is once you get it you can't
reverse it and so you're a liar okay so
why don't we have a little wager here he
says you're on
I said now since you're an eye doctor I
want you to pick 12 of your patients 12
of your worst patients that have max
regeneration I've been legally blocked 6
8 10 years you give me those 12 patients
and what I want to do in this wager is
we're gonna put them on my diet we're
gonna put them on my supplement program
and at the end of 90 days if I could get
half of them if I could get 6 out of the
12 to be able to read 20/20 in the 90
days would you apologize in public buy
me a nice bottle of Cabernet and take me
out to Ruth's Chris Steakhouse for a big
steak dinner he said you're on I sit
down remember you're going to pick the
patient
so there shouldn't many question about
the diagnosis so the next day he brought
me 27 charts the patient have been
legally blind 6 8 10 years they said
well why don't we take them all I mean
you got 27 here let's take them all he
said okay he's I'll even do better since
you're gonna take them all I'll just say
if you could reverse one of them even
reverse any one of them in 90 days so
they could read without glasses and
they're legally blind 6 8 10 years I'll
comply by buy you that steak dinner if
it's the steakhouse I'll give you the
bottle of wine and I'll apologize in
public I said you're on so I came out
with my protocol and of course I spoke
to each one of those patients myself I
didn't want to depend on that eye doctor
doing that properly doctor pew right
he's an eye doctor in Salt Lake City and
to make a long story short in 90 days 25
of the 27 could read 20/20 it took
another two weeks for the other two to
be able to get that far and he complied
he bought me the bottle of wine he took
me out to Ruth's Chris Steakhouse and
one of my big meetings with a couple of
hundred people there he apologized for
calling me a liar because I could
reverse Mac degeneration I've been doing
it by the thousands every year since
then it's one of those things were that
was probably the most direct in my face
I mean they sued me a lot but when it
came to most of the time it didn't get
past the original court interviews in
this any other the evidence that I had
to support what I'm saying was so
overwhelming my degree in agriculture
and I just bring in all the animals dad
also and so they were just flabbergasted
on you know the doctors side well you've
never seen anything like that
well that's because you think you know
everything you discount the value of
information that veterinarians have and
so you know you think there's sort of a
third rule professional of their
veterinarian and you discount everything
they say you know go give some rabies
shots to a dog kind of attitude and so
I'm both I'm a physician and a
veterinarian and my patients they laugh
about it they say doc you treat us like
dogs but we get better okay let's take
an L summers case reign McGregor I can
give you that name because it's a very
famous story he was diagnosed 11 years
before I knew him
with alzheimers disease doctors treated
with pharmaceuticals and he is from
Charlotte North Carolina
the name is reine McGregor he's
diagnosed with a disease and began to
treat him with pharmaceuticals trials
for disease dementia in three years time
he got worse and worse worse went into a
coma he's in a coma for 11 years he's
being fed through g-tube with insurer
which is the worst possible thing to
give him is amazing live that long
because it's made from oil
no real scientific supplement program
and his sister came to me really and
distressing look they're gonna pull the
plug on my brother ray he's the mantras
almost at zero brainwaves and he's been
fed through the g-tube he's been in a
coma for eight years there anything you
can do okay let's give him three or four
eggs three times a day through his
g-tube with soft yolk soft pokes whip
them up put them in one of our shakes
made with heavy cream not water and then
we're gonna give him the healthy brain
and heart pack a full dose for
everything three times a day we're gonna
give him the D stress capsules through
those twice a day through the Jeeto you
know open them up and put the powder and
the and the stuff here and the food your
give them through the g-tube the
ultimate niacin plus we're also gonna
give him the ultimate daily classic
tablets grind them up and put them in
the shakes going through the g-tube to
make sure there's blood flow in case
your vaster dementia in there let's just
go for it call me in two weeks in four
weeks in six weeks when she calls me in
three days crying and weeping and I said
oh we got a problem here
well I said well how's your brother ray
and she just septic a kept yelling on
the phone
ray McGregor ray McGregor ray McGregor
as well tell me about your brother ray
and she said well he got up this morning
he shaved he got into a three-piece suit
he went back to work as a bank is one of
the vice presidents he went back to his
office inside of the desk working and
all the people at the bank were freaked
out because none of them had ever met
him before because he went into a coma
was in the in the nursing home before
they even worked at the bank again their
thing and this is a weird way he's gonna
rob the bank and so that's my most
famous dementia story ray McGregor
okay I mean and you know okay so and we
deal with this all the time okay another
great story true story is we have a
patient who was on dialysis for 25 years
in the last ten years or in Dallas's six
days a week because they hadn't peed in
ten years and your name
ten years turn balances six days a week
for ten years make a long story short we
got em on the dot
gonna run the 90 cents of nutrients got
him on the ultimate daily classic to get
blood flow into the kidneys and in two
weeks time they dropped the number of
dialysis treatments from six per week to
now three per week because it started
urinating after ten years or not
urinating and then another six weeks
we're totally off analysis because
didn't need dialysis anymore because
kidneys were perfect on lab tests
that's the cause when you have kidney
issues when it comes to kidney failure
the blood test shows the kidneys are not
filtering the blood almost always it's
due to a different problem so I'm due to
a kidney problem even though the tests
show the kidneys not filtering the blood
is due to the fact that the kidneys
aren't getting the dirty blood because
the arteries that carry the dirty blood
and the kidneys are blocked so we treat
it as an artery problem as opposed to a
kidney problem get rid of all the bad
foods all the inflammatory foods get rid
of fried foods processed meats oils
gluten as we brother.a notes and sugar
get them on the biggest hammer in the
toolbox and then we throw in the
ultimate daily classic tablets to
support healthy blood flow through the
blocked arteries and support healthy
blood pressure and almost always almost
100 cent of the time people be able to
get off at Alison's go back to normal
life I do have any of those stories but
ms is part of a class of diseases I like
to talk about parkin disease MS ALS
which is Lou Gehrig's disease
Huntington's disease these sorts of
things you could throw in dementia into
that same class because they're all
about chemical deficiency problems in
the case of MS there's also an
inflammatory issue added to it that's
why they have the plaques in there by
getting rid of all the inflammation
fried foods processed meat so I was in
glutens taking again the biggest hammer
in the toolbox a Health abandoned heart
pack the ultimate daily classic tablets
for circulation into the brain to get
rid of the plaques for MS we have amused
these things like few Cloyd see
VTT 2.0 tablets to get help the white
blood cells and the antibodies get rid
the inflammation in the brain make sure
they're eating three or four eggs with
soft yolks
three times a day to repair the myelin
or the white matter of the brain and all
those diseases will go away
all those diseases go away and people
say well why do you give so many
different products well because there's
eight different dimensions and when you
have MS you could also have parkin
disease at the same time because they're
all literally the same disease the only
difference is what part of the brain is
more severely afflicted and that's sort
of an accident of chance okay because
all parts of the brain do different
things so if part a the brain is more
severely affected you're going to get
diseases that are reflected a reflection
of a problem in those processes that the
a part of the brain does if you're
looking at a disease is found in the M
part of the brain just by dumb luck that
part of the brain was more severely
afflicted and so you get different
symptoms they give it a different name
and so that's why we have Park disease
MS ALS Lou Gehrig's disease that's why
we have Huntington's as that's why we
have all these different dimensions
because of location location location
but they're all nutritional deficiency
diseases
you